[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
seems like a light news day doesn't it
oh speaking of light
how heavy you think that fat [__] is I
think we're gonna find out what his
weight is I almost guaran goddamn tea
we're gonna find out how fat Donald
Trump truly is
from the uh booking at Fulton County uh
there's some crazy [__] going on down
there I'm going to show you some videos
of that today uh we're gonna watch some
video of last night's debate I'm going
to give you a this first 30 minute rant
is going to be about how the Republican
party does not believe in the
Constitution anymore that is
I haven't been saying it forever that's
part of their problem actually that is
the problem that they have is that they
don't like the Constitution they don't
like it so I'm going to explain uh that
and it's very apparent last night from
the debate the Republican party is dead
it is dead
it's [__] dead there's no Reviving it
there's no recovering it we can't put
paddles on it to get the heart beating
again it's [__] dead
and Trump keeps throwing [__] dirt on
its grave good [__] them [__] em that's
what they wanted that's what they've
wanted for years let them have it let
them have it uh speaking of Grandpa
poopy pants Donald Trump is supposed to
uh prepare for his fourth
perp walk today
he's getting arrested again now this
one's significant
in that it's going to be a little
different than the other ones
because now you have a sheriff
that is not going to kowtow to this
two-tier justice system he's gonna
process him just like any other
small-handed [__] that would
walk into his jail
good
Donald Trump is supposed to be putting
up two hundred thousand dollars Bond
that's the largest Bond so far I think
Rudy giuliani's was 150 000 where do you
think Rudy got the money to put up 150
000 Bond yesterday huh
I don't know there's a bunch of crazies
outside the uh Fulton County jail today
it looks like a goddamn circus down
there I have a unique video that I want
to show you
I was very very [__] confused this
morning when I watched this video I was
very confused
but after I thought about it for a
little bit and remembered a video that I
showed you the other day
of Nick Fuentes the Nazi that's right I
was like hmm maybe maybe just maybe that
all makes sense
and it it just it just kind of proves
the point of what I'm saying is the
truth
is that it is a cult it's a [__] cult
and they're not walking away from trump
it was clear last night Jesus Christ did
you did you guys watch any of it I
didn't watch the the thing I had karaoke
karaoke is very important my my my
relax and have fun time is very
important I I got I gotta get away from
some of this [__] sometimes
so that's a very important time every
week that I do that I may have a few
drinks sing a few songs
have some fun get the hell away
decompress from the [__] right this
the onslaught of these [__] fascists
who can't help themselves but hate the
Constitution and it was clear from the
clips last night
Chris Christie
is the only one on the stage
he's the only one on the stage that
could actually beat Joe Biden I believe
that I think Chris Christie if he were
their nominee he could have a really
good shot
at beating Joe Biden dead serious as as
awful as that sounds because that's not
a good that's not a good alternative
oh okay Chris Christie's not some kind
of oh he's for Liberty and freedom Chris
Christie's a [__] box he's a scumbag
okay
but he's the only one on the stage that
has a chance to put a republican in the
White House
or the only one not on the stage too
because obviously there was some um
mango Mussolini who was not present
but Chris Christie is the only one the
only one folks that is the only one and
the reason why is because Chris Christie
spoke last night at one point and he
didn't give a [__] how much they booed
him
he was gonna stand he was gonna actually
stand on that stage for the Constitution
now
I want to give you some back history
here well I want to rewind a bit
because Chris Christie and the rest of
these [__] idiots
don't actually
value the Constitution no matter how
much Chris Christie says it and he can
say it all day long all he wants
he knew
in 2020 when he was prepping and caught
covid from Trump
and almost died from it he knew the
disdain that Trump had for the
Constitution he knew in 2016 the disdain
that Trump had for the Constitution
and last night Chris Christie spoke
about it
with again
in a waterfall of booze about how Trump
does not he did not hold his oath
to protect the Constitution he wanted to
suspend the Constitution
now my question to Chris Christie
if I had the opportunity to ask him a
[__] question
which I don't know that that's out of
the realm of possibility but if I ever
did have the possibility to ask Chris
Christie a question I would say
why now
Chris Christie why now do you value the
Constitution
why now because you were you were
hell-bent on making sure a man who
didn't who wanted to [__] on the
Constitution who does not respect the
Constitution
wanted to be president of the United
States he was and then you tried to get
him reelected where were you then Chris
Christie huh you really think you really
think Donald Trump has changed his view
of our constitution since since giving
Chris Christie covid get the [__] out of
here with that nonsense this guy has
never liked the Constitution that is the
problem that we have in this country
that's the real issue we're not divided
that's all [__] [__] we're not 50
50. half of us love Trump and half of us
hate him that's all [__] [__] the
majority the country hates that
[__]
they want him to go the [__] away
honestly I think a lot of people in this
country would say if he would just shut
his [__] mouth
and go away forever
and stay quiet
and be a good little boy
then we don't give a [__] if he's
prosecuted or not I think there's there
would be a big percentage of this
country
that would be for that idea
there was some kind of deal of course
we're way past a [__] deal here but
if there was some kind of deal where
Donald Trump goes away forever and not
be prosecuted I think the country might
say well I'd take that deal if she shut
his [__] mouth they are we are so
[__] sick and tired of this piece of
[__] trash
it's exhausting it's [__] exhausting
to have to not only fight fascism but
fight that white trash [__]
in the fight for our democracy because
that is what was apparent last night
is that the Republican party does not
believe that our constitution is
valuable
and the Republican party has been a cult
for a long time and for a long time they
have acted pretended that they like the
Constitution
but they hate the [__] Constitution
they [__] hate it oh they [__]
hate our country they [__] hate that
document and the reason why is because
it affords people civil liberties Rights
and Freedoms
that's why they [__] hate it
and they've those [__] fascists have
hated that document for a long time
it didn't just happen in 2016.
give me a [__] break
every time every time one of the
Republicans last night stood up on stage
and pretended pretended that's right
Chris Christie Mike Pence Nikki Haley
you [__] Pretenders you goddamn
posers
every time they pretended to like the
Constitution
every [__] time they were booed
they were [__] booed
our problem is not the [__] Marjorie
Taylor greens the Lauren boberts our
problem is not the [__] Jim Jordan
gym I don't report sex crimes Jordan
Matt I'm a pedo gats
James Comer
these are not our problems Donald Trump
is not our problem they are a symptom
of the problem
the problem that we have in this country
is that a a portion of our citizenry
absolutely believes that the
constitution is out of date
and the reason why they believe it's out
of date is because it affords people's
rights and liberties
that Constitution is a living document
it was designed to be a living document
it was designed to advance and progress
to more diversity equity and inclusion
in this country
as much as we possibly could achieve as
a collective and a whole
not as individuals you [__] our
individual freedom is given to us so we
can advance our nation as a whole
and they [__] hate that
oh these white Christian
[__] fascist these nationalists they
[__] hate it
look no further than the debate stage
last night
and it's very clear honestly I I I hope
they do a republican debate every
[__] day from here until the Iowa
caucus
the American people will absolutely
reject and dunk in the trash the
Republican party wants and for all
the more they do what they did last
night
the more they do it oh a [__] rake
stepping everywhere
couldn't stop [__] couldn't stop
digging their political grave
and last night last night not only did
we not take the shovel out of their
hands we gave them big [__] backhoes
big [__] backos
now the big story oh Trump and Tucker
were licking each other's balls
what a disgusting [__] display of
people who hate the Constitution
speaking of people who hate the
Constitution Tucker Carlson and Donald
Trump
and the reason why those two [__]
scumbags hate the Constitution is
because it equals the playing field
against Elite privileged white men like
them
that's what they [__] hate about it
they've hated it they've hated it for
the last quarter or a half century the
last half century they [__] hated
ever since the Civil Rights Movement
they [__] hate the Constitution they
[__] hate it
and they would prefer to rip it up and
tear it and put it in the trash burn it
[__] on a piss on it the entire thing
[__] the Constitution that's how they
feel about it it's clear it's clear as
day and that's the problem that we have
in our country it isn't division you're
so full of [__] [__] media I [__]
hate that when they say that [__] on the
media and it makes me not even want to
turn them on because these are not
serious people reporting to you
they're not they're not [__] serious
when they say our country's divided it's
like 50 50. no it is not that is a bunch
of [__] [__]
is trumpism heavily heavily concentrated
in areas yeah because those people it's
designed to be delusion in those areas
[__] I've had Jess Piper on several
times to talk about this [__]
in rural areas and the Trump trump
country
Trump is a symptom of this disease
and the disease is is that the
constitution
the delusion is is that the constitution
will afford the wrong people rights and
Liberties and take away your privilege
which is [__] just wild stuff wild
stuff
and no wonder no wonder the oppressor
feels oppressed Jesus Christ are you
[__] kidding me
[__] Country Bumpkin ass white people
thinking that because someone gets the
same Equity the same equality
under the law and the Constitution that
somehow something's being taken away
from them that's not what they're scared
of folks
let me tell you let me tell you a little
[__] secret
get in Real Close turn this [__] up
do you know what do you know what rule
white people are scared of do you know
what they're [__] terrified of
they're terrified
that if people have the same Liberty
equity and quality is them
that there's a chance there's a chance
that blacks Mexicans brown people
lgbtq community will treat them the way
that they want to treat those
communities with hatred and oppression
that's what they're terrified of
that's what they're scared of they're
scared that if we give if we give
someone else the rights and Liberties
that we've had forever they'll treat us
the way that we've been treating them
that's what they're terrified of
full stop and it is clear
that that as as a unsorted unsorted
Coalition of [__] boneheads
that this after being brainwashed for 40
years by right-wing media
and the right wing and churches [__]
churches in this country these white
Christian nationalists it is clear
it is clear
that we have a small percentage it's a
large number of people but a small
percentage of people in this country
that are absolutely [__] brainwashed
and and deluded to believe that the
constitution no longer serves their
interest because it doesn't love white
people
plain and simple you want the truth
there's the [__] truth you may not
like the truth you may go Tony that's
all man you're going way too far you're
a race Trader God damn you can't you
can't pin up all white people like that
the [__] I can't
that's the [__] truth of it and even
P even people who vote for the
Democratic party who are part of the
pro-democracy Coalition still hold
somewhere deep down inside them the [__]
they were taught when they lived in
rural areas trust me eyes no
deep deep deep down inside you and
that's where I'm digging this from folks
I'm not telling you this because it's
some kind of [__] Revelation that
I've had
I'm telling you deep down inside White
America the white Christian nationalists
that were raised in in that white
supremacy institution in this country
deep down inside them way deep down in
there
they're terrified
that the constitution will press them
and it'll allow
folks that aren't white to oppress them
what do you think the CRT [__] is what
do you think the book Banning is
why do you think they don't want drag
shows Jesus Christ Rhonda Santos is
[__] Bannon drag shows in Florida and
the guy's putting makeup on last night
wearing high heels give me a [__]
break Ron you [__] piece of trash
[__] you [__] you and anyone who likes
you [__] you Rhonda santis I'm glad your
political career got ruined last night
you destroyed yourself you dumb
[__]
you should have listened to me when I
told you to resign as Governor way back
and run for president as soon as Donald
Trump was arrested and the man in
Manhattan you dumb son of a [__]
there's dog [__] out there that is
jealous about how [__] stupid you are
Ron it really is
just hang it up man listen you you
[__] the Republicans the
Republicans have until New Hampshire I
was listening who was it this morning on
MSNBC that I was listening to because I
wanted to see what their analysis was
because I know it was gonna be [__] I
knew it was gonna be [__] and I I don't
care if you watch MSNBC and you like it
I don't give a [__] I'm gonna keep
speaking out against the the media when
they say stupid [__] [__]
they just don't get it they don't
[__] understand
they got their [__] noses way too
high and they're not paying attention
they're trying to be right they're
trying to be correct they're trying to
make sure that oh man six months from
now want to make sure that my commentary
is gonna be absolutely correct just say
what the [__] you mean then
they were talking this morning John
Kasich John Kasich was on [__] MSNBC
the guy who got smoked by Trump rolled
and smoked by Trump in 2016.
the former Republican governor of Ohio
talking about oh there's a long ways to
go in this race a long ways to go no
there isn't you dumb son of a [__] and
you know it
you got till New Hampshire to find
someone other than Trump and there is no
clear path not one
there is not one clear path last night
the only person that can beat Biden on
that stage are has a possibility of
being buying on that stage which is
Chris Christie got [__] booed the
whole night
and you think that motherfucker's gonna
win a primary
you think you think the way if you
believe polls the way he's pulling in
New Hampshire he can pull that out
you're full of [__] John Kasich you're
full of [__] [__] and they need to
get these [__] off TV it's
enough of this [__] it's enough of this
[__] where we gotta listen to these
[__] people talk a bunch of nonsense
like they know better than us [__] them
this is our [__] country this is our
[__] democracy we are the government
we are the [__] people
we do not have to [__] listen to a
bunch of [__] on the television
telling us what the [__] we can and
can't do and what the [__] we should
think and how we should feel about
what's happening in front of our [__]
eyes
they're taking [__] rights away I
don't know if you've been paying
attention there's videos out there I
ain't got no [__] time we should I
gotta do a five hour show a day to do
this [__]
there's [__] videos of the moms from
the Covenant School where kids little
children were gunned down that are going
to session
and just asking these [__] scumbag
Republicans not to pass a law where
teachers don't even have to disclose
that they have a [__] firearm in a
goddamn School in Tennessee
and they're holding signs and they're
kicking them out of [__] session
public session their [__] government
and you got this whiny little [__] from
Mar Lago whining about how I committed
crimes in Georgia and it's so [__]
bad that they charged me with crimes
that I committed [__] you Donald Trump
and Rudy Giuliani you [__]
their parents
in Nashville Tennessee
who watch their children get [__]
gunned down and Republicans not only not
doing anything about it they're doing
the opposite to make sure more children
get killed
and they don't give a [__]
because they don't care about our
country they don't give a [__] about you
they don't care about the Constitution
and John Kasich doesn't give a [__]
either
no he doesn't
if John Kasich gave two [__] he would
say the truth he would tell you the
truth on the [__] TV tube he would
say we are headed for Donald Trump to be
the [__] nominee it is possible that
there is going to be someone in federal
court state court on over a hundred
[__] felonies
and our party no longer loves the
Constitution
we have walked away from Liberty and
freedom
and we have embraced fascism
he would tell you the [__] truth he
would tell you that all those
[__] on stage they may not
think they're Nazis
but the Nazis think they're [__]
Nazis
and that's the [__] truth and if you
don't like the truth fine that's fine
whatever if you don't want the truth
fine keep listening to [__] that makes
you feel good
but I'm here to tell you I'm here to
tell you that if you want to advance
your democracy you gotta get with the
[__] truth
and the truth is we don't have two
parties in this [__] country we don't
because under our constitution we're
supposed to have two and if one doesn't
[__] wholeheartedly believe in that
Constitution and that [__] document
then they're not a major party
so we're not [__] divided media
and anyone else who says that [__]
horseshit we are not divided that is a
bunch of [__] there is a small
percentage of people in this country who
have been [__] brainwashed into
believing that the advancement of the
Constitution will oppress their white
asses
it's white supremacy it's white
Christian nationalism and they can't
stand for the Constitution because the
Constitution will not tolerate it
and we the people the government us the
[__] Republic
will not tolerate it either and they
know it
and they know the clock is ticking
so what are you gonna do
are you gonna cower from the truth
are you gonna be mad
because the truth is is that there isn't
a Republican party they're [__] dead
there isn't one of them that's electable
not one again I'm telling you last night
on the stage the only [__] that
could beat Joe Biden and I bet he could
be Joe Biden is Chris Christie
and they [__] boot him they booed him
and boot him and boot him do you think
he's gonna be the nominee the Republican
party when he goes to a debate and
anytime he says the word constitution
they [__] boo him
think about it let it [__] sink in
John Kasich there's not a lot of time
left dummy there's not a lot of time
left in this primary you [__] idiot
I'd say it to John kasich's face
I hope he sees it to be quite honest
with you I hope MSNBC producers watch
this [__] the [__] they're producing
it's not non-biased it's to make it's to
make people feel good
let's make you [__] feel good
well we shouldn't feel good about what's
going on we should be [__] pissed
yeah we gotta laugh at it we got to be
cathartic we gotta mock the [__] out of
them but we shouldn't feel good about
this stuff
they're running rough shot all over our
[__] democracy and they're hell-bent
on destroying our constitution that's
what they want to do that is their
[__] goal that is their mission and
it is clear last night
that not one Presidential nominee not
one are presidential candidate for the
nomination on that stage
on that stage other than Chris Christie
now pretending he loves the Constitution
oh he loves it now
oh yeah when when when Trump was giving
him covet during the debate prep that
[__] the Constitution then Constitution
now not then Constitution now
because a bunch of [__] money is
paying Chris Christie to act like he
loves the Constitution now where the
[__] was Chris Christie in 2016 when he
knew Donald Trump would [__] all over
the Constitution huh where were you
Chris oh that's right you were trying to
seek power that's what you were trying
to do you know give a [__] about the
Constitution the [__] out of here
these people have no principles
don't you know that by now why do you
think they elected Donald Trump
he gives them permission to be the worst
version of themselves
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
sit back he's gonna oh what what John
Kasich tell you that there's oh there's
so much time in this primary there's no
time left in this primary Trump's
already won you dumb [__] he's
already won he won the day he announced
because it's a cult
don't you get it
take a take a deep breath
and what what the debate last night sink
in that [__] interview with Tucker
and and Trump that's typical [__] that's
typical privilege [__] Silver Spoon
white dude white supremacy [__]
there's nothing [__] special about
what happened on Tucker Carlson uh
little stupid [__] interview last
night nothing [__] special nothing
surprising it's exactly what it was
designed to be
but last night on the stage on the
debate stage what you should have
brought away is that the Republican
Party 100 hates the [__] Constitution
and they want to get rid of it they want
to trash it
I know it feels good to say Chris
Christie man he was really defending it
he was really they were booing him
I'm not talking about the candidates
folks the candidates are a symptom Trump
is a symptom of the [__] disease
he's just a symptom
I've got a special guest with us here
today Tennessee Brando he joined us a
couple weeks ago
about a song
a song talk about small towns and the
delusion in small town
Jason Aldean song at [__] the bed did
you know that you know what I I think I
said when I first heard the song That
Song Is [__] objectively it's a horrible
song the lyrics were [__] they weren't
they weren't even good they weren't even
put together good they were just like
how can we how can we piss off liberals
and black people let's do that
and the music uh [__] Jason man get a
[__] different career man and by the
way if you're gonna talk about a small
town maybe you should go to one every
once in a while
instead of acting like you're from a
small town Macon Georgia get the [__]
out of here get the [__] out of here
with that [__]
but there's been a new song that's been
released I haven't talked about a lot on
the show
so I wanted to bring Tennessee Brando on
he had a video out the other day talking
about these different the music that's
happening
the music that's happening and how it's
How how our culture is shaping around
music and what I want to ask him is this
new song
it claims to be like the plight of white
people and Appalachia but to me the
lyrics
are the exact opposite of what that is
so don't go anywhere when we come back
Tennessee Brando is with us again right
here on the Tony Michaels podcast don't
touch that dial
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show don't
forget to visit the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com get over
there if you want to get a venmo chat in
the links is at the top make sure to
follow us everywhere you can and
subscribe to us everywhere you can it's
a lot of places you can do it for free
free 99 five finger discount on it boy
I'm excited about this yes I'm about to
handle on it again Tennessee Brando
joins us again he did a video the other
day
um and I believe I forget he calls it uh
the songs we've been debating the songs
we've been debating it feels like it
feels like every 30 minutes when I say
that every 30 minutes of the show today
like these are the songs that we are
debating and I'm gonna break it down and
yell and scream into this microphone
uh so I want to welcome back to the show
my friend and music extraordinaire
because I'm telling you he pumps out
songs like there's no tomorrow Tennessee
Brando Tennessee Brando how are you my
friend I'm doing good man it's good to
see you again hey you too you too so I I
watched this video and I it's it's a
couple minutes long so I'm gonna retweet
it so the audience can go Um can go can
go look at it but you were talking about
in this video and that's why I was like
I gotta have him back on to talk about
this and I didn't even expect when you
came on today that this would be what
happened last night on the debate stage
but it truly is man it truly is because
I was talking about in the first 30
minute block and I know you've talked
about this a lot before about you know
the plight of White America and white
supremacy and white Christian
nationalism and this delusion that
they've come to that the constitution no
longer serves their purpose because it
gives the people they don't want Liberty
and freedom so tell us about these
different songs and how you see this uh
and looking through your periscope your
perspective well when I heard Richmond
north of Richmond first
um like when I very first heard it comic
I think I came across it on Tick Tock
um you know we have an artist in this
part of the world Tyler Childers who has
red hair he's had the same red beard and
a lot of people around here after Tyler
blew up and had success a lot of people
around here began trying to imitate him
so my first gut reaction was okay here
comes another guy trying to imitate
Tyler Childers he's got the same look
got the same voice and everything and
it's like he had me at first I'm going
okay like maybe this guy's gonna say
something and then he just takes it in a
completely different direction and
starts demonizing the obese and and
saying them milking welfare is the
problem and right then it was like he
went from talking against the rich men
north of Richmond to just embracing
their talking points and that's where he
lost me it was like if he'd have said
that line different the line where it
says if you're five foot three and
you're 300 pounds my tax dollars
shouldn't go to pay for your fudge
rounds or whatever imagine if he'd have
said you know if you're living in the
finest town and you've got millions in
your bank account then my tax dollars
shouldn't go to give your ass a break
right I mean there would have been a
completely different reaction from the
ride and it was so funny to me that last
night they opened the debate with that
song and asked Rich politicians how that
song was resonating with working people
that was hilarious
as if Rhonda Santas as if Ronda santis
would ever would ever be be um anywhere
near understanding the plight of poor
folks like in Appalachia right yeah but
in this case yeah go ahead yeah yeah and
his answer was that the way he said well
our country's in Decline and we have to
take it back from Joe and Hunter Biden
that was basically his answer you know
right so well and and you know this goes
to uh because the right wing has been
losing their mind speaking in a Joe
Biden because I I actually said the
other day a lot of people didn't like
that I said it but I actually don't
think Joe Biden in the white house
should have went to Hawaii as soon as
they did there's no reason for Joe Biden
to actually go to Hawaii as soon as he
did other than right wing pressure and
he and and I think that they kind of
bent to the pressure and they did a
number to him on Fox News acting like he
wasn't empathetic and and you know the
the thing is is that that's what that
song reminds me of it's like okay how do
I make the plight of poor white people
in Appalachia right because we have we
have a ton of Folk Music to pull from a
ton of lyrics a ton of History to pull
from and we talked about this the last
time you're on and they went in the
total opposite he went in the total
opposite direction with this because
it's not about it's not about the actual
plight it's about pandering to an
audience the same thing as Jason Aldean
when he when they when they wrote that
song and it almost felt to me like it
was like okay that I think they realized
what a train wreck the Jason Aldean song
was and they right they realized there
was really no way to defend it so it was
like they got behind this song and tried
to twist the narrative in a different
direction
to act like that they suddenly have our
best interests at heart and it's just so
hilarious to me that that that's the way
they would take it and there was a lot
of other you know dog whistles in that
song he's he's talking about how that uh
they want to know what you think they
want to know what you do you know I feel
like he was kind of dog whistling to a
lot of the conspiracy theories right
there and the Q Anon crowd that you know
that says the government wants to
control our life especially life and
then you know he made a reference to
Epstein island in the song There was it
was it was mainly right-wing talking
points in the tune and I think that's
why they got behind it I don't like I
said I think if that one verse has been
a little bit different they would have
had a completely different ration and
probably wouldn't have got behind it
bushes like they did so this
singer-songwriter his name is Oliver
Anthony right yeah and then his name and
in the song that you're referring to is
Richmond north of Richmond and so tell
us tell us about the title of the song
and the artist that you that you know of
and why is that title Richmond of North
Richmond north of Richmond what is that
what does that mean what does that mean
because some people in the country don't
know what that even means Billy's pretty
much referring you know he's from
Virginia and so he's referring to
Washington DC when he says Richmond
north of Richmond Virginia you know is
what he's going for but um
like I said it just it just it real
quickly it went from he was he was just
they got against those rich men to just
embracing their talking points that was
like that was one that was the weird
dynamic to the whole thing for me it
isn't bad trumpism in it basically in a
nutshell yeah absolutely yeah I think it
definitely was and I'm I'm surprised I
don't know if Donald Trump said anything
about the song but I'm surprised he
hasn't because it it just it seemed like
that it was
you know it was a way of blaming other
people and and I heard uh coach D that's
on Midas Touch a lot I heard him make a
really good point he was saying you know
okay if you're going to say that the
that's the obese or milk and Welfare is
like how can you pass judgment on
someone if you if you see someone out
there getting a bag of fudge rounds with
a with a EBT card you know how can you
pass judgment and say this person needs
it or die or don't you know what I mean
it's it was a very I don't know it was a
very punching down lyric to me that just
kept us fighting amongst ourself and
distracted well let's listen to a little
bit of this uh this song if you want to
call it that
um now this is that this is the artist
um that the right wing oh man they love
him he's all over the media now and
everything's so cool right and it's it's
really honestly it's an own the lib song
just like uh just like uh try that in a
small town same thing same thing own the
lib song because they they knew they
knew what the lyrics meant and they knew
who they were going after
um but it has a different sound to it
right yeah it sounds like a folk song
and what what's the answer what's tell
the audience what the instrument that
he's playing here that's a that's a
resonator guitar and those things do
sound really cool and a lot of folk
artists use those
um and he's definitely you know he I
will say he's not going for your typical
bro country Jason Aldean sound here
right he's tapping into what I was
talking earlier that that's that Tyler
Childers vein there's a Tyler Childers
song called nose on the grindstone and
if you go listen to it it's very very
similar in the way that did the delivery
not necessarily the melody or the or the
music but the the delivery of the voice
right so so what you're saying is maybe
someone was listening when we were
saying hey bro country sucks I yeah
maybe maybe they were listening I don't
know I don't know maybe they're
listening but let's listen to a bit of
this uh this song and let's see if we
can figure out why why the the
candidates on the stage and why they
Pander to people who believe this this
stuff
I've been selling my soul working all
day
over time hours
for [__] pay so I can sit out here
and waste my life away drive back home
and drown my troubles away okay so I'm
gonna stop it there and the reason why
I'm gonna stop it there is because the
lyrics so far in the music so far it
sounds like this guy would probably vote
for I don't know a politician that would
be for the people exactly not not for
corporations not for their own power it
seems like it seems that way right yeah
I mean that that's that's what the sense
that you get from the music so far and
that's what I said like when I heard
that like right there he had me I'm
hooked at that point going okay like
let's see maybe right maybe something's
gonna happen here but watch watch what
happens it's a damn shame what the
world's gone to for people like me
people like you wish I could just wake
up and not be true but it is
all it is living in the new world
okay so there it is there's the start of
it the new world world the new world and
again this is what I was talking about
with this debate because it was clear to
me on the parts of this debate that I
did want or that I did see is and again
the the moment when Chris Christie's
talking about the Constitution and the
crowd is just booing him I'm like holy
actual [__] did these and I I don't know
who Oliver Anthony is and I don't know
if he's smart if he's not if he knows
history if he doesn't I don't I don't
know it doesn't seem like he knows
because if he knew anything about
history he would understand that the
plight of poor people the plan of poor
people was part of it was done through
labor unions part of it was done through
minimum wage part of it was done through
through actual rights I don't know
people know this but the reason why we
have a five-day Work Week there's a
reason why we have a five-day work week
and I don't I don't know if I don't know
if Oliver Anthony understands how how
the Constitution and how our democracy
was used to get that five five day work
week which it probably should be less
than that to be going on so we should
have way more workers rights in this
country and labor rights in this country
than we do and we should keep pushing
for it which a lot of people are out
there on strike doing that we we watched
as the UPS or uh yeah UPS uh got their
their pay we see the writers striking
uh we see sag striking um but Oliver
Anthony here doesn't seem to know what
documents actually afford him and the
reason why is because some of these next
lyrics and it's the same thing the
Republicans are saying on stage last
night let's listen
[Music]
Lord knows
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so there he's talking about how
they you it's amazing to me that
Republicans and conservatives and
Christians in this country are like yeah
this is exactly the problem that we're
having people are telling us what to do
and what to think so we should
definitely pass laws to get rid of
certain types of people we should pass
laws where you can only have a certain
type of religion and we should pass laws
to where if you don't have this type of
thought and religion that we have you're
not invited and you're not welcome in
our country it just I don't know it
feels like
Oliver Anthony doesn't understand what
the word Liberty is and how it's
delivered in this country is what it
feels like all of a sudden in the song
Am I Wrong
no I don't think so like I said I think
I think it's it's speaking of that voice
that
um that thinks you know that everyone's
out to control them and and their way
but again you know it's still at this
point in the song If you're listening
you don't know what's coming next you
still could be a person that feels like
okay I can relate to this it still feels
relatable for me you you could you could
bend it that way it's still open for
some interpretation right right
and what and then the reason why that is
is because
he's slowly walking to the point that
he's going to get to right exactly and
it's it's what Trump does every time
it's what DeSantis does it's what all
these [__] fascists do is they they
slowly walk to the point to where
they're like yeah you know what if
someone's coming on the wall just shoot
him just execute him right there like
Ron DeSantis is literally saying that
out loud if someone if someone crosses
in the imaginary line that is enough for
the death sentence and we should just
execute them on site like no explanation
no no due process no justice no nothing
just kill them like that's literally he
they have slow walked themselves to just
shoot people at the border it's [__]
Insanity it's [__] insanity but they
slow walk themselves so much to this
point just like he's slow walking in
this song Let's listen yeah
thank you
[Music]
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not just minors on an island
somewhere Lord we got folks in the
street ain't got nothing to eat and the
old Beast milk and Welfare oh God if
you're five foot three and you're 300
pounds taxes don't not to pay for your
bags of fudge rounds are putting
themselves six feet in the ground just
hold this damn country does is keep on
taking them down
lord it's a damn shame what the world's
gotten to the people like me people like
you
like you now I I I'm not one to uh get
too technical here about uh body shaming
but this guy doesn't I mean he looks
like he knows a thing or two about fudge
rounds I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not I'm
not gonna lie to Tennessee Randall so I
don't think he's against fudge rounds I
think he's against people uh not paying
for their own fudge runs I think is what
he's getting at here but it's again now
we're slow walking to this this point to
where it's if you're on welfare you're a
piece of [__] yeah you're a piece of
[__] if you're on welfare yeah and it's
funny how he says you know we got folks
in the street that's got nothing to eat
it's like when is the Republican party
ever cared about them right you know
when have they ever had any ideas or
that's the thing too about last night's
debate is we really I mean I didn't
watch the entire thing but I watched a
good chunk of it and uh all I heard was
mainly we're gonna take they just kept
saying we're gonna take it back we're
gonna take this country back we're gonna
we're gonna get rid of this we're gonna
cut this right I didn't hear any ideas
so so as far as helping feed the ones
that have nothing to eat okay it's good
that you you that you've got some you're
bringing some attention to the fact
there's folks in the streets with
nothing to eat but what are those people
doing to help those people
I I couldn't agree with you more and the
and that one one thing that you could
example that you could go to with
Republicans is governors
um there's a couple Democratic Governors
um one in Pennsylvania
um uh Shapiro
they actually signed into law to make
all school lunch free for all kids
not not only in Pennsylvania is lunch uh
nutrition but now it's part of your
education right yeah and that's the way
we should March nutrition as part of
Education like the actual eating and you
know and giving supplement to your body
should be part of your education in
school in public schools that's what it
should be
but here this this song is advocating
for groups of Governors like Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
and the the governor in Iowa who want to
not only not only want to make sure that
kids don't get lunch given to them at
schools but want to take
free and reduced lunch away from
children so Oliver Anthony is advocating
in this song that oh people are in the
streets and don't have anything to eat
and all the children they all man the
children but [__] the children [__] the
children when it comes to schools
because that's handouts and we can't we
can't do handouts to children we can't
take care of the children we can't save
the children and give them nutrition at
a public school
yeah you know and those rich men in
Richmond ah man oh man those Richmond up
there they're making sure
they're making sure that your your kid
doesn't have anything to eat and it's
all a bunch of hooey it's just [__]
it's backwards ass [__] isn't it it
is yeah and I I did hear an interview
with Oliver Anthony I don't remember if
it came out before after the song he was
talking about how that you know he said
I'm down the line uh I'm independent I
shoot down the middle politically I
don't lean left or right
but you know now all these right-wing
politicians have embraced the song and
you've got them using it at the debate
so it would be interesting to hear now
what he has to say you know because it
just strikes me that anyone that ever
wrote a folk song that was trying to you
know protest the way people were being
treated I can't imagine I can't imagine
Woody Guthrie uh being excited oh he
would be pissed can you imagine if the
Republican Party had adopted one of
Woody Guthrie's poems that said oh we're
going to use this you know he would have
raised hell about that and so he could
have probably burnt [__] down oh yeah so
it's like it so to me he can say all day
long that he shoots down the line middle
middle of the road but right here is
your golden opportunity to say no that
was because my question would be you
know you said Richmond north of Richmond
he said politicians was he only talking
about Biden and the Democrats yes yes
and that and that's really goes to the
heart of the issue that really goes to
the heart of the issue and the problem
that we have and the problem that I was
talking about in the first 30 minutes is
that that and part of this country and
we're not divided you know I I hate I
hate when the media says that I hate
when anyone says that we're divided we
are not divided that's such [__]
that is such because you know this even
Trump supporters
um where you live and and then around
you if you talk to them about specific
issues they're gonna be kind of where
you're at on specific pinpointed issues
it's just they've been so [__]
deluded and brainwashed into believing
that the only people who are going to
deliver them the solutions to those
problems are rich white Republicans yeah
like that's that's the delusion that
they have it's not that they don't want
and and I don't think Oliver Anthony
wants children to starve in schools
right I I I don't I don't I think what
he's saying is that people shouldn't
starve and people shouldn't be hungry
but he's brainwashed into believing that
the only way to do that is white
Christian nationalism that's the only
way to do it that's the only way that it
gets done there's no other policy other
than that and that's why he's probably
happy that they used his song at the
Republican uh debate and to your point
it actually makes his song just
completely full of [__] if he's excited
about it right yeah exactly because if
it was you know there's been several
times I'm trying to think of an example
but there's been several times that
people politicians have used songs uh
and then the person that wrote the song
I think seemed like Tom Petty one time
reached out to somebody was like stop
using my song and you know things like
that so I mean you know if you don't
want to be associated with something you
wouldn't be and it's just it's just
weird that now I I said it almost felt
like that they realized what a train
wreck uh the Jason Aldean song was and
they couldn't defend it anymore so they
got behind this one they're trying to
take the heat off that one and look how
fast that one plummeted out of the
conversation I mean we were having this
debate about it what a month ago or so
we were right yeah well you know yeah
well you know that that the Alabama boat
rash happened yeah that that was one
thing and I think that tamped down this
idea that hey uh if you come to our
white town and you're black you can't do
that in a small town because that's what
the song was about man I mean come on
come on I I grew up in White America
where the whole town was white it was
Sun downtown you know don't let the the
sun hit your back I'm
that's just the way it is and still in
some parts of America and I believe that
Oliver Anthony here is is uh certainly
either placating to an audience or he
believes this stuff but to the Jason
Aldean thing
and I know a lot of people don't like
the music that we've been blamed from
all our all of Oliver Anthony here but
it is objectively better music oh yeah
than what the Jason Aldean and I I don't
know you know different people have
different preferences but there is
objective uh better objectively better
songs and this is an objectively
musically not the lyrics and not the
attitude not the direction not what he's
actually singing about but the song
itself how he's singing the style is
objectively better than Jason Aldean's
song it is and there's a lot of people
that loves that style and that sound and
it's it's something that's more popular
in the underground world but like I was
talking about earlier you got artists
like um Tyler Childers right uh who's
much more Progressive in his viewpoints
uh Jason Isbell much more Progressive in
his Viewpoint Sturgill Simpson a lot a
lot of people out there are making music
and I noticed that they never shine a
lot on those they never lie those aren't
those people aren't the mainstream well
but let me ask you do you think that
that Tyler and those other musicians are
more Progressive are there just singing
about their authentic experience well
yeah you're right you're probably right
about that because they are singing more
about their experience and then it gets
it gets put over there on that box if
that makes it right right well because
they're telling the truth you know I and
I I speak about it a lot on here about
the media you know the media is like oh
we don't want to appear biased I'm like
biased to what the truth like why why do
like well they'll think we're Democrats
and they'll think what progresses well
who gives a [__] I mean the truth
doesn't care about your ideology it
really does not give a [__] the truth
doesn't care about anything but the
truth and and and that's why uh Tyler
and the other artists that you were
mentioning that because they're
authentic and they're singing about
their experience and not only that Tyler
you know in his music and his lyrics he
places his experience in other places
right yeah you know he he takes his
experience and he tries to use his
experience to empathize with other
people who don't have the same
experience because we all have different
experiences we're all we're all
different we're all different we're from
different parts of the country from
different towns different families
different religions sometimes so it's
not always the same but Tyler's really
good about empathizing with his own
experience and I think authentically
that's how he appears to be Progressive
is that he's just empathizing he has uh
right you know
you're absolutely right about that and
you know one thing that he did back when
he released the song along violent
history uh he put out a message with
that song because he he realized that
people can interpret things the wrong
way and and uh so he put it out there
letting people know that this is this is
what he was trying to go for that was
that was that was back in 2020 right
that was in 2020. yeah this was after
the George George Floyd had been
murdered in the in the protest
um and and when that all happened
um Tyler kind of kind of wrote this song
about it and then he put a message and I
actually played the message on here and
it and that was that was you know three
years ago but it felt like to me when I
saw it and I think I actually sent it to
you I'm like this feels this feels like
a rebuttal to Jason Aldean three years
before Jason Aldean thought to even sing
that song yeah
it still Rings true today you know if if
you stumbled across that for the first
time and you didn't look at the date
that it was uploaded you could easily
think he said it now because it's still
it still applies right in that picture
but in that a [__] about the truth that
the truth that the truth that the truth
and authenticity can really transcend
and and live for a long time and be
relevant for a long time when their lies
and their [__] about oh the 300
pound man beating fudge rounds as if as
if the majority of of America is on
welfare and buying fudge rounds and
being 300 pounds is the biggest problem
that we have in this country
obviously there's a lot more issues that
we have we we need mental health care
and we need it fast like really fast
yeah Tennessee Brando give us your give
us your last thought um I'm glad you
joined us today too thank you for having
me but give me your last thought and
tell tell the audience where to find you
well you can find me on pretty much
everywhere on social media under
Tennessee Brando uh if you don't spell
the word Tennessee out it's abbreviated
on uh at different platforms TN
underscore Brando uh like it is or I'm a
name here um you can find me there and
uh I'm on YouTube Facebook Instagram
Twitter X whatever you want to call it
uh threads I'm even on there and you can
find my music on Spotify under Tennessee
Brando that's that's where that's where
everyone should go go check out we
played Tennessee Brando songs uh a lot
on the show here so go check him out on
Spotify you also got a pretty big
Facebook you do you do well on Facebook
over there too so go follow them on
Facebook yeah you can find me there too
that's great that's great Tennessee
Brando thanks for joining us again my
friend come back soon and and when these
songs pop off and when they release
whether it's a good one like Tyler has
that is authentic uh and and has empathy
in it or it's like uh Oliver Anthony's
here which is just a bunch of hooey and
[__] come back and visit us and tell
us I appreciate it everyone stick around
we'll be right back with more right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
I guess people noticed that I was a
little pissed off
am I ever not pissed in the first 30
minutes thanks for joining us thanks for
sticking around here Tony Michaels
podcast Tennessee Brando I actually I
invited Tennessee Brando on before the
debate I had no idea we were going to be
able to tie in this song Richmond north
of Richmond uh into the debate but we
absolutely did because they're totally
100 predictable they're predictable
they're predictable as [__] uh I I'm
trying to see if we can get Gabe Sanchez
to join us but apparently his skunk has
been turned loose somehow his skunk
that's right I I guess his pet skunk is
running around his apartment building
and causing wreaking wreaking all kinds
of Havoc no funny doesn't it uh so
maybe we'll get the uh maybe we'll get
the guy with the last name Sanchez maybe
he'll round up his skunk I'm not kidding
you that's what he typed me I don't know
what to tell you don't blame it on me
I'm not lying here I only tell the truth
you know this
he says he says that there's a skunk
loose in his apartment building and I'm
just here to out him and no no no
Samantha Samantha says I'm tricking I'm
not tricking you no I'm not I'm not
tricking you I'm serious
he that's what he said he said long
story dealing with the skunk in our
apartment building that's what he said
now I I question rather this is actually
his skunk or someone else's skunk I'm
not really sure I'm assuming that he has
a pet skunk that's what I'm going with
that's the conspiracy theory that I'm
going with
I also want to pull up another comment
here from Leslie on YouTube she says
Republicans want us divided you know
they uh Leslie more than that
they want us to believe
that we are divided
that's what they really want they want
us to believe that that is why I yell
and scream the way I do every single day
here
for two hours
because they want us to believe that
that we're divided and when anyone tells
you anyway because it's not just
Republicans when anyone tells you that
oh we're divided it's 50 50 right down
the [__] middle
half the country loves Trump half of
them hate him that's all [__]
and when they're saying that they want
you divided too
they want you divided
they want us to be divided and like I
was talking with Tennessee Brando
this Oliver Anthony character this this
guy that's singing this song trying to
trying to capitulate to White Christian
nationalism as if as have you been to a
trump rally Oliver Anthony have you been
to a trump rally
lately and seeing the [__] 300
Pounders that look like that's all they
eat is [__] bad bags of fudge rounds
I just want to know I I I'd have Oliver
Anthony on honestly I would probably
[__] just destroy him but I would
have Oliver Anthony on asking these
questions I'd let him I'd let him go
back and forth with me fine yeah sure
let's do it friend
but has he ever been to a trump Rally or
seen video of a trump rally
these people that show up has he has he
noticed
now what he's talking about truly
is that
he's talking about Republican policies
leaving rural areas in the dust
that's what he's really truly talking
about but he doesn't know that's what
he's talking about he has no clue and
the reason why is because he's deluded
and he might be deluded from I don't
know
you know whether it's the fudge rounds
himself I mean it looks like Oliver
Anthony is eating his fair share fudge
rounds I'm not gonna lie I I love a
fudge round too who doesn't [__] like
Bud drones
who doesn't like [__] fudge rounds
who doesn't
um
I might eat my words here and because I
said that uh some someone someone
thought I was just
um what the hell someone's asking what
is a fudge round maybe we can get an
expert on here to see what a fudge
around is
um I I know I know it's pet skunk got
loose uh out of his cage and he tried to
round him up but apparently the skunk
has been rounded up and put back in its
cage because we have the guy with the
last name Sanchez joining us Gabe
Sanchez did you get your skunk under
control no I don't oh you I don't know
where the skunk is man I lost oh my God
what's your skunk's name
Harold Harold the sky yeah yeah become
Harry you know that you know that
there's going to be a bunch of Gabe
Sanchez skunk memes pop up in the disc
yeah so this is
I just I just Unleashed this whole
[__] subculture of Gabe Sanchez and
skunkism in the Discord I have a feeling
for people who don't know the financial
members you don't know you got to go
over to the Discord because it gets wild
over there it's where the chat never
stops and I'm sure I'm sure this is
gonna and I'm not like trying to force
it or anything for people to make it
means but I might be it is what it is
yeah a fudge round is a little chocolate
cake right yeah a little Debbie yeah
Widow Debbie it's a widow I saw I saw a
t-shirt somebody sent me and it it was
let me see if I can find it hold on
really quick I'll go back to the skunk
in a moment yeah well we'll get to the
bottom of the skunkism here all right so
the business
there's this t-shirt that my buddy sent
me because Little Debbie and uh let me
let me see if I can find it all right
here we go why you're why you're finding
that if if you're not if you're not in
the Little Debbie aisle
uh in the grocery store
you're probably not American I mean I'm
just going to be completely honest I
mean there's a Cosmic Brownies you get
the Swiss Rolls I mean you can tell you
could tell my asses
been in the little Debian yeah no we all
know your fan A Little Debbie but are
you a fan of pull the image okay oh okay
well let me let me see you may be a fan
of Little Debbie but are you a fan of
big Debra
now I know why you're laughing
oh my God
oh
uh is Discord going wild over this I'm
sure they are I do skunkism but now now
we're all up in the [__] and now
we're all up in the big difference big
Debra serves up skunk cakes big old
Deborah skunk cakes huh yeah okay so
let's get to the bottom of this skunk
Story how did your skunk get loose so
it's not my skunk there's a neighborhood
there's a neighborhood skunk the skunk
stuff is already happening oh my God so
the other thing the other thing if
people don't know about Discord you can
actually communicate in the chat there
you know like the YouTube chat's really
fun but in the in the uh Discord you can
use uh memes and gifts so like it gets
kind of wild over there uh fart squirrel
uh no I don't own a skunk uh there's a
skunk in the neighborhood okay so is
this like is this like the neighborhood
skunk like everyone sees it
no you don't see it
well you've never answer this thing
you're always like
Gabe around I grew up on a farm in
Central Missouri you don't think I know
what a [__] skunk is I don't know
Tony I'm not sure about big Debra I've
had we've had dogs that we had to like
douse and bathe because they got near a
skunk yeah pissed them off scared him no
basically there is there's a skunk that
is somewhere in the neighborhood but it
hangs around the building and late at
night it's like and it like you know he
has a gun it goes
wait wait wait wait wait wait you gotta
do that again what is it
what does he have like a little mini gun
or something out of his [__] anus
glams
shooting he's oh you're saying he's
shooting his scent yeah you're like
I mean he could come in with guns and
he's like um
know if it was like you know because
there's Pepe Le Pew right yeah yeah yeah
so I didn't I didn't know if it was like
a cross between the skunk on there on
Pepi
yeah that's it that's it that's it and
like Yosemite Sam like yeah
right an alt-right skunk or something
yeah
uh no so anyway there's this [__]
skunking area
I'm debating whether I should get a
t-shirt
okay good but there's a there's a skunk
that is in the area
and this morning last night
it's like oh it kind of smelled it
whatever we close the window this
morning we woke up and it was like
definitely the scent was out there right
like it's close yeah like this is this
is closer than normal and then a text
chain goes around with the building
people are like oh I smell it it's like
we're in the we're in the the front of
the building and the people are like oh
it's very strong in the back and I guess
the Texans are trying to figure it out
and they're like we think it's somewhere
like it's found itself in in one of the
walls of the building like down on the
ground floor
and it maybe is trapped and it's just
[__] going
and it's just like [__] going into
the walls
so does does your room right now as
you're currently sit it's a minor scent
I'm on the show
with a I can smell it as I'm talking
it's not it's not super strong you need
to get your [__] skunk under control
over there yeah you're all right to a
bro skunk over there
once I look once I catch them I'll
[__] de-gland them and I'll be like
you're my little boy you're my son or
daughter whichever I don't know what it
is
either way this thing is somewhere in
the back of the apartment and it's just
going
so uh skip says on um
on Discord you all [__] need
Jesus because they're they're just
popping off over there on the Discord
I'm telling you it's the best of the
best on the Discord if you're not over
there you need to [__] get over there
quick fast and in a hurry small rad says
you get your ass out there and you find
that [__] scarf
you know what I don't even think we need
to do this show anymore we just let the
Discord do the show to be quite honest
wow the one they call Gabe
y'all [__] do need some Jesus
yeah Lord they got they gotta get they
got a little clip of GIF of uh [__]
uh Lil Dicky from his music video
holding up a skunk Gabe when he finds it
oh my god
oh so so some people didn't know what um
what fudge rounds were but speaking of
groceries and grocery stores last night
I think one of the best Clips because
you know it's Tucker Carlson Donald
Trump interview is like it's just normal
[__] they're like we're a bunch of pissy
ass white guys rich Silver Spoon
[__] and we're just gonna hate
the constitution in America that's what
we're gonna do we're just gonna like I
think one point
um Tucker Carlson calls his former
colleague Chris Wallace uh uh fussy I
think he calls him a fussy [__] or
something like that I don't know while I
haven't watched the full interview I
know I'm sure you will didn't have to do
it what was that on I'm sure I'm sure
you will even I saw people tell me I got
what was that on that and also debate
and this this clip here this clip here
is [__] fantastic dude does not know
dude does not know that you do not need
your ID to buy groceries but let's let's
listen to this fat [__] a convention
but to get into vote if you buy
groceries if you buy any practically
anything now you have ID no what
this is
when's last time you used your ID in the
grocery store do you remember when I
bought alcohol when you bought alcohol
wait they still card you yeah dude with
this baby face man of course they card
me they're like what are you 19. oh oh
you think you're gonna buy alcohol yeah
like really they're really like
scratching it to make sure it's yeah
they're like taking [__] they're like
[__] black light they're like all
right cut the lights in the cut the
lights in the grocery store
this guy's definitely gonna fake this is
a pretty good fake man oh man now that
and it's got the reflective [__] real
ID
I'll let you get away with this once all
right
the the Babyface skunk memes are about
to drop uh in the Discord here
um but Donald Trump does not know this
is okay so if you rewind way back to the
the early 1990s right in 1992 when the
president at the time George H.W bush
was running senior yeah yeah yeah senior
the the old dude the one that's dead now
he's dead he's d-e-a-d he's like I mean
he's like dead and he's not like super
dead but he's dead yeah he's dead dead
so so he he actually he went to a
grocery store and have you ever seen
this clip no go see if you can pull this
clip George H.W is scanning groceries
receiving Finance George H.W bush goes
in a grocery store and they're scanning
the groceries like on the conveyor belt
right like boop boop and he's Amazed by
these like holy [__] what is this
sorcery where you can just scan an item
he's Amazed by it now this is like 1992.
okay the scanning groceries have been
around for a while but he was so
disconnected
so disconnected from the way American
Americans live that he had no idea that
when you go to a grocery store you put
your [__] on the conveyor belt the
conveyor belt moves to the little
scanner spot and they scan the groceries
to calculate how much you owe them right
he had no idea about barcodes or any of
that [__] it's wild stuff wild stuff but
how in the [__] is this moment where he
does not know that you do not need an ID
to buy apples oranges and milk and bread
the same
as George H.W bush not knowing the
sorcery of barcodes
are you finding it yeah I think I found
it it's a PBS yes yeah yeah all right I
I I'm hoping this hasn't I wasn't able
to watch the clip okay well let's let's
see if we can pull this up here and I'll
show you this moment
and you can tell me if you think it's
the same [__] [__] as what wait hold
on wait maybe
let me see if I can find is there a
moment this is like a
this is covering him
wait wait wait wait wait let me see well
it's only it's only a minute and 51
seconds so let's let's see oh it's it's
when you get to go to like 118 is if you
scrub through to 118 I think it's where
he's gonna find it
okay let's start here here has been the
worst of my political
yeah it's a coverage of George H.W bush
hold on
it's gonna go into it the next month he
was skewered for seeming out of touch at
a Grocer's convention
he marveled at new technology that could
read a shredded barcode
the New York Times said he didn't know
how an ordinary checkout counter worked
the story stuck because it fed in with
what was being argued by uh his
opponents both on the far right and on
the Democrats so there it is lost time
yeah so there it is he's lost touch he
didn't know what a girl
what is this what is this magic that you
that you have in front of me George H.W
bush discovers fire
crazy like they just entered entered the
running water or some [__] you know what
I mean like whoa and then Donald Trump's
like yeah you need your ID to buy
groceries and all of his supporters like
yeah yeah you I I mean I don't but I
know everyone else does I mean I've
never been did you see the trailer for
The Show
for the for for what the Tucker's thing
yeah yeah no I didn't watch that no
there's a clip at the very end
yeah of the trailer
yeah yeah yeah
sorry I'm sorry I saw there was a Justin
Brad raffensberger and election
investigator Francis Watson has been
speeding yeah all right uh Tucker
Carlson okay so he had a trailer where
he was like okay everyone come watch
this show right because I don't know if
you saw my tweet yesterday but I said uh
Tucker Carlson should have gone with my
original title that I pitched him
Tucker on ecstasy because now the show's
called Tucker that is that is kind of
well Elon did kind of [__] in there you
know what I mean because Tucker spent
not a lot of time or a lot of money on
his Graphics
also it just sounds it just sounds like
it's extreme like before it was like it
had an intro where he was like [__]
All-American he was like fly fishing you
know it was like a you know wholesome
kind of thing and then I was like took
her on eggs
so this is this is the actual this is
from Tucker Carlson's account and this
is the trailer this is the trailer for
like what you're gonna see okay so of
course and of course they're the most
like
they're like the Highlight moments of to
obviously get people hey I mean if you
want to call them highlights right yeah
low lights whatever right but if you at
the very end because it definitely like
ramps up but I think it's maybe the
middle to the end is When Donald Trump
has his line about
Twitter and it has it shows the
disconnect of like where he at is at
understanding technology and what's
happening okay well let's let's take a
look why are you at the Fox News debate
tonight in Milwaukee well you know a lot
of people have been asking me that you
say there are people on stage who
shouldn't be running for president
Michael Pence he's out there attacking
you what is that do you think Epstein
killed himself sincerely do you think
we're moving towards Civil War
[Music]
it's good to have you at Bedminster it's
very nice I love it you're saying they
stole it from you last time why wouldn't
they do the same this time oh well let's
try
Mitch McConnell is trying to get
Senators to impeach me crooked Joe Biden
is so bad he's the worst president in
the history of our country I don't think
he's going to make it to the gate but
you know you never know it started with
protests against you minute moved to
impeachment twice and now indictment are
you worried that they're going to try
and kill you why wouldn't they try and
kill you honestly they're Savage animals
they are people that are sick so do you
think it's possible that there's open
conflict I can say this there's a level
of passion that I've never seen there's
a level of hatred that I've never seen
and that's probably a bad combination
we're doing this interview but we'll get
bigger ratings using this crazy Forum
that you're using then probably the
debate
no they won't
uh I love that you're on ecstasy Tucker
on ecstasy it would have been a way
better show if he had just done what I
had [__] pitched him but whatever it
is what it is he doesn't like [__]
feedback or critics doesn't ever he's
not really open-minded but that's just
Tucker that's who he is okay so truly is
a fascist he truly is a [__] Nazi uh
but Tucker Carlson he releases his thing
and and Donald Trump's like oh on this
crazy thing you've got going on here
this forum it's a [__] video on
Twitter there's nothing that you are not
Reinventing the Wheel video has existed
on social media sites for for years wait
wait wait wait wait you act like social
media is a place where people can share
ideas photos and videos or something
it's almost like it's a it's a hub it's
a network
are you saying that is the purpose of
social because I feel like you're saying
I don't want to claim that I know
I feel like you're saying that social
media is a place where people can share
video I think that's the false claim
you're making uh look I'm just look I'm
just calling as I see it you and your
[__] facts I tell you and so when I
heard when I saw the trailer because
again they they filmed this beforehand
and then they were like why aren't you
at the debate tonight you've probably
found it like two days ago okay but uh
in that one moment he's like yeah you're
probably getting more views and you know
or better ratings than on this crazy
Forum here than the the mainstream media
you know no he's not people yesterday
like Nick sorter the guy who's going
around Maui and harassing Oh you mean
the journalists yeah the Jer the the
citizen journalist who got put in a
headlock because he was trying to force
his way and like
put make contact with uh with the mayor
of Maui
what you didn't see that I lost this
story I mean
we played the we we showed the clip
where I said this is what he's trying to
do why I I I I yeah basically long story
short what he tried to do was he was
trying to force his way in as a
journalist yeah and and the mayor was
like look we're done because this is
here and anyone who doesn't know this
already
Nick Sorter and there are other
right-wing conspiracy [__] deep State
Pizza gate type people that are out
there and they're trying to push this
conspiracy that there's their child sex
trafficking ring happening and it's
coming through Maui
hang on a second so you're saying that
they're thinking that this fire has to
do with the blood-sucking cabal
pretty much they're trying but they're
all doing it they're doing it under save
the children so they're trying to say
wait how many how many children are are
the cadavers how many bodies are the
children do you have a number do you
have a total you know the number tell us
a number and they're like look
we don't know
we don't know or we won't comment on it
right we're still recovering we're
getting evidence we're getting proof
and so uh Nick sorter who I've had
several conversations in spaces with who
definitely has he's uh definitely has an
ulterior motive when he's asking
questions let's write a link conspiracy
theory is Trump loving cuck he's a
dumber he's a dumb [__] yeah when you
hear his voice and you see his face
you're like that's not the that's not at
all how I match these two up right so
he's at a press conference and their
journalists are are asking the mayor
like hey what about the stuff what all
the stuff he brings up and this other
guy who's in the back is like how many
children are missing how many dead dead
kids are there how many dead babies all
stuff we want answers we want answers
and so Nick tries to get his way through
and then all of a sudden you see the
camera turn and he's put in a [__]
headlock but you don't see the head like
you but he's like I was just putting a
headlock by the you know the mayor's you
know security detail whatever and it's
because he's trying to force his way
through yeah because they're saying
crazy ass [__] and smoking fear were
done music because I find it hilarious
that they're using this moment as save
the children
[Music]
um when they could be paying attention
in Tennessee have you have you seen this
and I we haven't given this much um air
time
yeah this this video specifically uh
Tennessee holler and if you guys aren't
following Tennessee hall or follow them
uh everywhere whatever social media
platform you're on you'll find these
videos of these uh mothers
um from this the school Covenant that
was
um had a mass shooter and children
murdered in the school and and those are
asking of the Tennessee
um subcommittee is not to push through a
bill that would allow teachers not to
disclose that they're carrying guns in a
school because they know that more guns
means more dead children that's what the
mothers well they don't like stats and
they don't like research or data and so
they don't accept the fact that more
guns equals more problems right so so
these mothers brought in signs that just
identify them in the subcommittee's uh
session as mothers from covenant like
that's that's what that which by the way
Republicans have used as a right proper
talk a a talking point improp to attack
trans people right but but in the
committee hearings they actually kick
them out they kick them out for holding
these signs but let's let's watch a
little bit from Tennessee here upset and
emotional and one of them sat down with
me in the aftermath and says it was
confusing and shocking and just left
them completely Raw
how do you feel right now
um a little shaken up you know I think
being here in general is raw
I don't think these people get what this
means
we're here for six people that were
killed at our school
we're just trying to do something
I think it's hard to be here it's
overwhelming we walk past the proud boys
I'm sitting with the TFA in front of me
and I'm just trying to sit quiet I
already got taught I can't have my sign
that says I'm a covenant mom that
dignity has been taken away
you know we try to testify for a bill
and get kicked out of a room it's just
really overwhelming
so there there there's uh one mother's
account of what's going on in Tennessee
now you know you would you would talk
and you would talk to somebody like
Nick's order save the children say that
what are you doing to say the children
all this [__]
and they're like yeah take away people's
Liberty take away their people the
Liberty to even say in a subcommittee
hearing about a bill because their their
elected officials the the officials that
the mothers elected are trying to pass a
bill that would put more kids in danger
and they're trying to speak out against
and they can't even identify themselves
with a simple sign
so I I find it um a bunch of horseshit
when we hear say the children from these
[__] idiots
um it reminds me of a moment of signs
speaking of signs that we need to hold
yesterday
when Rudy Giuliani did you see the the
clown car coup sign I saw his little
presser yeah so the guy with the the guy
with the the sign yeah so here's the
Rudy presser and really you know don't
pay attention too much to what Rhys says
because he's an asshat all right this
guy's an asshat he's a liar he's a
traitor [__] this guy the guy still is
trying to push the idea I mean he has
the same or said he plans to do the same
thing at Mark Meadows did right and got
rejected which was hey hey this no no
this is not a state level thing I want
to put it to the federal court and it'll
be dismissed and it'll be allowed to be
removed from the state court wait you're
saying the FED said [__] off is that
what they said I'm saying that yeah
pretty much like look man this [__] no
this ain't gonna fly it's in a federal
thing this is a state level thing you
guys try to [__] do this in the state
level right good luck [__] good luck
[__] and Bonnie Willis is having none
of this but neither was this guy holding
a clown car who wants this this is great
on Donald Trump and his lawyer I
will you be here tomorrow
well I didn't do that I entered into a
stipulation for the purposes of that
case to move on I specifically says I do
not in any way I admit the truth of
those allegations those allegations are
totally false you did not contest that
you made fraudulent claims about the
2020 elections wrong and you're lying as
you often do if you read it it says it
was only for the purposes of that case
and it was not an admission
so he's like I only admitted to lying I
only made it to lying particularly about
that case so I'm not sued yeah that's I
I'm I'm lying about lying because I
don't want to be sued and for anyone
wondering the case that they're talking
about they're bringing up is the uh
sheamos and
he had he settled the case basically
what happened was he agreed that he made
false and defamatory statements about
them
but he's not claiming that he made false
statements about the 2020 election he's
just saying oh okay yeah I lied about
them having a thumb drive but that
doesn't mean that I am lying when I say
that the election was rigged what I'm
saying is that it was corrupt it was
rigged and Donald Trump won the
presidency this guy is so [__] lost
all right Rudy colludi Lincoln hair
Giuliani Mr Congeniality right here with
the mug shot and all
oh [__] these mug shots are great though
Rudy's Rudy's a good one but Jenna Ellis
was even better yesterday
um and of course Donald Trump's is going
to break the [__] internet this
afternoon yeah I'm not sure he's gonna
he's gonna actually you know what I made
a hold on I'll pull it up
here's Jenna Ellis uh her hers did she
think she was getting her driver's
license photo taken or some [__] what
did what did she think she's trying to
play the I'm a good girl
I'm a I'm a I'm a I'm a God lover
s that's what she did
she put on her Bible verses and was like
hey everyone when your enemies come
after you you just gotta smile and take
it there's something like that like
that's basically what it said it's like
when your enemies [__] come after you
and attack you then
um
then then know that like you should be
strong or some [__] like that of course
the other one they actually released the
Kraken yesterday or her uh no dude this
is not the Kraken this [__] is like the
[__] has anyone ever seen the nun
in the audience the movie The none it
comes from The Conjuring Universe okay
the nun I don't know that I've seen look
at the photo hold on I'll find a photo I
sent you a link by the way for Rudy one
of the things that I saw on the show
yesterday I was like I'm gonna make a
thing about Rudy oh it's just the thing
this is the thing I sent you last night
but I finished it so I was like this is
the thing I'm gonna make but I don't
want to say it loud because I don't have
his photo yet
and I'll probably make one for Trump too
well
let's see if I can get this thing
towards I have [__] thing zooms
automatically why is it doing that I'll
just do it like this here we go it's on
store that imgavesinjaz.com you go to
store.imgavesanchez.com to see this
picture live and in color or you go to
the Tony michaels.com click on the Gabe
Sanchez merch store it's Rudy's mug and
his booking number that's brilliant and
it's the actual photo there yeah real
photo we're not you know it's booking
photo and everything live from Fulton
County Rudy's mug I'll probably make one
that's like you know Trump's mug or
something like that but you can you know
take it take shots out of Rudy's monk I
don't you could [__] buy and smash it
you could buy it you could do whatever
you want with it the point is
Rudy's mug ain't going nowhere [__]
neither is my mugshot mayor he's not
going anywhere either yeah but anyway so
uh the one the one thing I wanted to
bring up was the nun uh really quickly
this is the image of the nun and this is
what like her one her face looks like
it's [__]
like it's got a creepy kind of wax like
right thing going on to it but when I
saw her eyes and they're like
[__] thing uh it may made me
think of
oh my God what the [__]
um let's see so why you're sending me
that
um because there's a circus
going on because we know Donald Trump's
gonna turn himself in is it this evening
that he's turning himself in what time
is it this evening it's supposed to be
happening I I saw that there was going
to be coverage at 6 p.m Eastern Jesus
Christ the [__] media man I tell you
what
coverage are they gonna oh look holy
[__]
that is Sydney pal that is Sydney Powell
I'm telling you holy [__] that is I saw
it and I was like oh yeah that is Sydney
power 100 that's her
um but you know I I was watching videos
this morning yeah
from the um in front of the jail there
that's the significant thing is that
they're gonna turn themselves in at the
jail not at the courthouse you gotta
turn themselves over to the sheriff
because these are our County charges
um now this video might be a little
weird to some people when I first
watched it I was like what in the actual
[__] is happening
in this video
um and and there's gonna be some words I
I might be [__] banned on on YouTube
I don't know but I'm gonna play it and
the reason why I'm gonna play it is
because I was I was very confused by it
at first I'm trying to I'm trying to
figure it out I'm trying to figure out
what why this is if you're trying to
make sense of this Tony good luck well I
actually I think I did make sense of it
a little bit okay and I'm gonna show you
this video and then I'm gonna show you a
video from Nick Fuentes I'm not [__]
you and I'm I'm gonna show you why oh
this makes sense okay so here's here is
I'm not sure who this uh this guy is he
says his name at the very end
um but he has a shirt on that's very
interesting you've seen the blacks for
Trump shirt this one is a little more uh
derogatory he doesn't use the hard r on
the shirt but
um let's just watch the video I'm here
to support president Trump
you wanna know why I'm here to support
president Trump because they didn't hear
black men like this for decades make up
charges and pull them so I know Trump is
innocent I support Trump I guess it's
corrupt two-tier justice system that's
why I'm here to show my support as a
black man for Trump and I'm wearing my
shirt [__] for Trump 2024 and I mean
what do you think about the indictments
oh it's a bunch of [__]
100 you know Fanny Willis she's a uh she
went to school with my sister she's full
of [__] she was full of [__] then so
she's a puppet for the white liberal and
that is controlling everything she's in
front but the white liver back there
pulling those strings telling her what
to do
that's what I think about it making a
fool of herself do you think it's going
to help his election of course it is
it's going to elevate him all the way I
think we should make Trump king that's
how I feel
it
wouldn't that be like kind of like no
there's no way okay okay okay so I was
watching this and I'm like what in the
actual [__] is going on here like this
is some wild [__] right because he
claims several different things and he's
gonna claim some more I'm gonna show you
the rest of it here yeah he claims that
the reason why he's in support of trump
is because there's a two-tier justice
system and the reason why is because
there's always false charges brought
against the black man so that means that
these charges against a rich white man
from New York an elitist
is the same thing I I know I don't think
this guy actually understands the two
tiers of Justice here I think he's
getting confused by that but here's the
thing here's the thing well it's because
it's because
uh well Trump
is an effective
uh let's say narrative spreader
propagandist weapon web weapon sure yeah
orator weaponizer tool
um but the reason that I think that
people are you know responding this way
is because the Republican party and
Trump have pushed the site this idea
if they come after you or if they come
after me that means they can come after
you and it shouldn't be difficult to
understand that that's only true
if you break the law well right but if
you commit a crime but it's backwards no
I know it's not if they can come after
you they should be able to go after
that's the thinking and that's why this
guy's uh understanding of the two-tier
justice system it seems a little skewed
but if you if you go to the part where
he's calling Donald Trump the king
of America it's really wild now this
person questions I was gonna say it's
almost like we left a certain country
and then came to this country to
establish the opposite of that right
right well and which this is interesting
listen to his answer this is interesting
and then I'm gonna show you because uh
most the audience understands that uh
the Nick Fuentes clip that I'm gonna go
back to because it's significant the
other day but and I I can tell you
remember but let's listen but not milk
Communists now we're just going to make
them King but we still got our freedom
to the right for everything you thought
that dropped for King 2020 that's
actually my URL
really oh my name is [__] for Trump
2020.
my [__]
I'm a former candidate for New York
State Governor Derek Gibson looked me up
what happens is the the police officers
coming up the road telling people to get
off the road and he kind of moves along
and nothing more significant after this
but the thing is is that the thing that
captured me in this clip
and the reason why I was like what in
the actual [__] is going on here yeah
I'm trying to figure this out
um because it to me it feels like
to me it feels like oh this this is kind
of an issue like in our discourse yeah
right that that this this stuff is being
portrayed backwards here
um but it's not surprising and the
reason it's not surprising is because of
where this narrative comes from and I
wish I wish this gentleman
could see the video
that I'm about to show here of of Nick
Fuentes
um I wish he could see it because I
don't believe that if he knew where the
messaging was coming from if he knew
were the things that he thought that he
believed because it feels like he
believes it done it to you I mean I
didn't have any other reason in that
video I think that guy was just
absolutely pretending
no but but I think if he knew where the
messaging was come come from because
listen to this listen to this clip again
see if you can pick out the same thing
the same language you're a [__]
immigrant
we have a we have a black immigrant and
if she's appointed by Obama another
non-citizen another
non-naturalized non-citizen from Kenya
presiding over a case of a former
president and a job Creator and a
billionaire and an all-around Titan
admired man
okay so let's stop there for a second
because we're not to the part that I
want to get to but
notice the pattern of language that he
that Nick Fuentes is pointing towards
fonny Willis and the pattern of language
that he the opposite for Donald Trump in
this case it's very very [__] similar
to how the guy in the glass clip I
forget his name now he says his name in
the clip Terry Gibson Terry Gibson I
think Gary or Terry Gibson yeah I tried
to look him up and I was not finding
anything about him so either he's didn't
do the thing that he said or or not the
person he says he is well or he's given
a false name who knows yeah the point is
is that the narrative
is exactly the same the undertones
exactly the same he disparaged foddy
Willis I know her I know her and she's a
fraud just like nymph Fuentes is saying
she's a fraud here and then and then
points
well let me just play the rest of this
clip because Nick Fuentes says something
very very similar almost exactly the
same
and this
person
is going to throw a wrench in and so she
controls the campaign that she's going
to talk to the king of America like this
like he's like they pull them over for
having tinted windows you're a criminal
like anybody else uh no [__] he's the
king of America you stupid
there you go he's the king of America so
I don't know if this guy watches Fuentes
I have no clue I don't know but I don't
know I don't know that but what I do
know what I do know is it's the same
exact language
the same framing of the situation that
is backwards a my opinion well
objectively it's backwards yeah because
in this country just because they can do
it to him doesn't mean they can do it to
you because they can do it to you yes
they absolutely can go after the person
in the top tier of Justice who is
normally protected because of their tier
of Justice just like Nick Fuentes is
alluding to here that they can't go
after him because he's the king but also
it it goes to say how much these people
are uh don't actually believe or maybe
don't understand the concept of a
democracy because they say we want Trump
to be king okay well if he's King then
he's not going to ever turn over power
and he would remain King for as long as
he wants to until he you know hands down
to whoever the successor is you know his
children or whoever would probably be
Don Jr because he's the one that
probably wants an elected of elected
position the most out of all of them
but when you hear talks to someone say
oh yeah King Trump King Trump you know
Daddy Trump he's the king he's the king
it makes you think like do you
understand how how that works do you
understand how power of the of that
person's position Works how long they're
in power or the fact that what you're
doing is stripping away any sort of
democratic system whatsoever
but he's like oh of course well I mean
we'll still have our rights nah you'll
have you no no no no you'll have rights
if Trump says you have rights if you
actually go through and get your king
you know your wish and your want your
dream of trump being King
he doesn't give a [__] [__] about you
he doesn't care about anyone keep in
mind this is the same guy who during the
2020 campaign got in a plane and
abandoned his constituents who showed up
or his potential constituents who showed
up to his 2020 rally and they all got
strained in the cold because the bus
didn't show up so people were walking
this is the type of guy he doesn't give
a [__] who you are he goes to Iowa only
because Ron DeSantis is there and he
wants to use it as an attempt to
um overshadow what he's doing
even though you know Rhonda Sanders can
do that on his own as we see in the
debate last night but Donald Trump
doesn't care about anyone Donald Trump
is number one and that's all he cares
about and if he has the opportunity to
throw anyone under the bus including his
children he will 100 I think you make a
great point is that these people don't
believe in the Constitution that's the
point I made in the first 30 minutes and
it proved last night on stage like when
I watched the clips from last night
because I didn't watch the [__]
debate I was doing karaoke God damn it
way more important way more important
yeah he threw paper towels in Puerto
Rico he was like what do you want okay
Kobe and he's like [__] throwing
shots from the point line you know
that's just like but last night when
Chris Christie was on stage and Chris
Christie brought up the fact that Donald
Trump said he wanted to suspend the
Constitution which is it's true he said
he typed it out on his [__] social
media account and he not only did he
type it out he's proven time and time
again that he does not like the
Constitution but last night when Chris
Christie brought up the Constitution
this way listen to what happened
with the crowd not not the candidates
folks because this is a disease that
these people are just the symptom of the
disease I'm about to show you watch this
you sit here talking about how you want
to stand up for the rule law yes and Law
and Order
and the fact is that it can't be
selective in your book you had much
different things to say about Donald
Trump than you're saying here tonight oh
it is very true it's very true I read it
and I know Prince movie
yeah I you know what I know a lot better
I know a lot better than you do you
like you've never done anything to try
to advance the interests of this
government except to put yourself
forward as a candidate tonight and
here's the thing we've stood up for Law
and Order I did it as U.S attorney I did
it as governor and I am not going to bow
to anyone when we have a president
United States who disrespects the
Constitution she said
it's important to say that the president
said
Donald Trump said it's okay to suspend
the Constitution
now both you take is to preserve protect
and defend not suspend I will always
stand up for our constitution regardless
of the political pressure we have
another question for you you're spewing
Chris Christie yep booing him about the
Constitution as much as I don't like
Chris Christie I'll give him props okay
for saying the things even though he
knows
that he's gonna have that type of
response you know it's a little late in
the game to be you know I won't I won't
go as far as giving him props I'll say
hey you're saying the right [__] now but
where the [__] were you where the [__]
were you in 2016 when you knew this [__]
where the [__] were you when you were
getting coveted from the [__]
debate prepping him for 2020. when you
wanted him to win and he knew he was
gonna usurp the Constitution you [__]
piece of [__] where were you where were
you Liz Cheney for 190 days after Donald
Trump lost you could have come to the
floor and said something for 190 days a
190 days folks and she's a hero Chris
Christie's a hero no they're doing the
bare minimum Chris Christie did the bare
minimum of what every [__] every
[__] politician should be doing in
this country saying Donald Trump crossed
the line when not only did he say he
wanted to suspend the Constitution but
when he clearly wanted to do it that's
what he's being [__] charged for in
two different jurisdictions now yeah so
give me a [__] break give me a
[__] break now I again I won't go as
far as giving props I'll say yeah you're
saying the right [__] you're supposed to
be saying but but Chris Christie the
thing that told me last night because I
believe Chris Christie is the only one
on that stage that could actually have a
chance to beat Biden I really believe
that I think I think Chris Christie is a
is a is a good enough retail politician
he [__] punches hard which America
likes I don't care what you say [__]
America loves when you punch hard that's
why Gavin Newsom is going to be such a
[__] huge contender in in the next
election it's because Gavin Newsom is
not scared to throw a hard [__] punch
and Chris Christie I think in the Gavin
Newsom might just be the [__]
nominees in 2028 but Chris Christie is
the only one on that stage that has even
the chance a beating Joe Biden and they
booed him they [__] booed him so they
don't care this is the good news folks
they don't care about their party
winning anymore
it's all about owning the libs and
getting rid of the [__] Constitution
that's what it's all about the whole
[__] in caboodle and the part the part
where Chris Christie's uh undressing uh
Vivek oh my God Chris pries
my veins Chris the one where well are
you talking about the clipboard he talks
he's like well she stole that speech
yeah well I mean I mean he he's he did
it a lot last night but Vivek didn't do
himself any favors here's here's one
point uh during the the debate where he
says one thing and then like a couple
weeks ago he was saying the exact
opposite watch this
climate change is also real I'm not
denying the under reality of the
underlying reality the global surface
temperatures are going up and so last
night it was a hoax because he knew the
karate he had to talk to yeah but a
couple weeks ago he was talking to a
Democrat so it's [__] real yeah I've
got a uh I've got a what was that that
I'm I'm wrapping up uh writing right now
and it's all about vivec and I go
through dude I as I always do and what
was that I [__] salute the internet
and I find the receipts and I pull up
every single talking point they've had
or crazy thing they've said and just as
last week all the [__] 911 comments
he made even though they haven't been
new
it's the guy is [__] digging himself
a grave and like hey you sure you want
you sure you said the thing that you you
think that you said that you're claiming
that you didn't say and he's like I
didn't say those things oh he's like oh
don't be like a petulant child Caitlyn
Collins and then variety's like okay uh
well I guess we have to now at least
he said exactly what he quoted because
if we
because that's the other thing too if
you're gonna challenge a publication or
an actual journalist unlike Nick sorter
to say hey what I said isn't real or
true they they clipped it they edited
it's no no I said something completely
different
for a big public publication or news
source if you ever accuse them of saying
no no you lied you manipulate what I
said
then they're gonna be like okay well
uh here we're gonna we're gonna prove
that we're innocent and that you said
what you said so here's the addition
here's the tape and also here's the
transcript for anyone who can't hear
hear what he's saying because this is
what he actually said and everybody was
like oh no no no I don't know that's not
no no this is all misconstrued they're
taking context out of what I said it's
like no they're not but here's what you
said about 9 11 and January 6 and you
meant it here's the thing though here's
what I want to show you because vivec uh
is ridiculous as he is as he's a plant
for Trump because I believe he's a plan
for Trump yeah he's only that well his
main goal on Bill well he also said
he would not accept a number two
position
so he's so he's he's acknowledged now
who knows if that's true or not knowing
what he's said and uh done in the past
but
he is because he's a known liar yeah he
said he he says he does not want number
two if given to if president Trump
offered him number two would he take and
he says Nope I want number one number
one is all that I know
and then on top of that when there was
the discussion of
um
his oh my God what was it uh I'll think
about it in a second I gotta remember
but
just yeah just going to the clip okay so
this so this clip here the reason why I
brought the Vivek lying thing in is
because this is their this is uh CNN's
little focus group here and you know
people who would vote for Republicans
now ultimately all the [__] and you
do you notice something in particularly
um white about these oh excuse me um
similar about these people can you pick
it out
anyways anywho I don't know I can't
figure it out anywho anywho
um watch watch as they ask the questions
about the candidates and then watch when
they get to the [__] liar Vivek this
is one thing again folks I'm telling you
it is a [__] disease and these
politicians are the symptom of the
disease these people want to be lied to
they want to be lied to you watch this
here's what I want to ask about who you
thought did the best during this debate
basically who do you think won the
debate I'm going to do an alphabetical
order to be fair anyone think Doug
burgum did the best
that's zero we never heard of that guy
before in our life he certainly got most
of the airtime yeah you think one Ron
DeSantis how many of you think
people out how about Nikki Haley
one two three four people wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
we'll get to the Vivek part but can you
believe Nikki Haley got twice as many in
this focus group and it's probably
because of the moment and give me the
clip of Rhonda Santos trying to smile
yeah trying his hardest to be a human
and trying to smile that's the moment
that probably did it for these people of
Nikki Haley being better but let's
continue here the beautiful thing is I
can just go to Twitter and I just type
in smile
are you serious smile on it no no I just
put in smile on the first video that
came up was Ron DeSantis is Ron DeSantis
oh that's [__] hilarious okay don't
worry I'm gonna have and people people
have been messaging me to do a [__]
what was that on this debate don't worry
this clip will definitely make it okay
so let's let's keep going with the focus
group here let's see how they feel about
the the the the liar vivec Rama Swami oh
ASA Hutchinson
Matt Mike Pence zero
the vague ramaswamy one two three four
five six seven I wonder why they love
their lives they love their lives I
wonder why but also it's like I wonder
why maybe because uh certain policies or
ideologies that vivec has might be
aligned with white people hmm very
interesting but the thing I was gonna
say before was yes on top of uh
um on top of vivec being there as you
know he says I'm not going to take
number two I'm only going to take number
one
he's a plant and I can tell you that on
top
of that
his role is is specifically targeted
to Ron DeSantis
and what's funny because Ron DeSantis is
specifically targeting vivec so it's
funny to see them fight and they're
attacking each other now Ron DeSantis
whether he's really running to be
president or not not that he has a
chance he's [__] torched any Legacy
he had when it came to his governorship
future run
they tried it again I bet they almost
try to recall him when he drops out
before Iowa I almost [__] bet they
try to recall I said this guy [__]
this guy any any person
despite all the crazy policies and
fascists uh uh moves that Rhonda Sanders
has made in the state of Florida
he has torched any sort of respect that
people had for him because now he's gone
out he's gone after they're you know
their King Donald Trump right he's
attacked him he's done do you remember
do you remember when he gained weight he
changed his suit he changed his hand
movements to he had a bit of a uh you
know he had a forward incline and hands
like this game combed his hair just a
little bit he gained like 30 pounds to
look like they're always waving you know
right and [__] [__] guy but this
this here this is
uh awkward to say the least let's let's
watch this clip here this is um
who baby uh Ron you need to get a better
a human suit it's weird and I will not
let you down
and I will not let you down
okay here's what I have to say Ron you
let us down immediately when you
couldn't even
get a smile out okay Gabe Sanchez what I
want you to do at this point in the show
is I want you to give us your best
Android authoritarian Ron DeSantis
meatball pudding fingers smile okay here
we go go ahead
[Laughter]
oh my God oh my God I'm tearing up over
here that's pretty good is is that how
that's how hard it is that's how
emotional it is it's uh just like you'd
think that like the emotion was honestly
like it's just leaking from my body you
know it's like once I did it it was like
shutting down and then just the
I'm gonna mute it here but I love the
part right before the smile let me get
to that point
he's using his tongue to shape the smile
right so here here's this like I don't
have a lip okay right stick my tongue I
he was gonna he was gonna lick his lips
or something it looked like him no I
think I think he did a bunch of training
before this debate and they're like look
Ron many things you can't do one do not
yell okay do not yell do not do your
weird creepy laugh do not lick your lips
do not do not use your hand to wipe your
face do not do any of that right and he
did most of the things
not to do don't wipe your boogers on
anyone don't do that and there may or
may not be a video of me behind the
scenes at the debate talking to Ronda
Santos in a video you know what you know
it gets me because there's another video
and I ain't gonna have time to play it
you're just gonna take my word for it
this this guy here that can't [__]
muster up a decent [__] human smile
right this game he is trying to ban
um drag queens right he wants to spend
drag queens once [__] man make him this
[__] was wearing high heels and
makeup last night on the stage can you
believe that [__] yeah he's gonna have
to be arrested when he goes back to
Florida no so not only do we have one
goddamn presidential candidate being uh
convicted or charged with 91 felonies
we're gonna have another one in Florida
has any Republican called JFK
a drag queen
I you know because you do know I mean I
don't know if people know this famously
I don't know if people know this but
they're um the debate between him and
Nixon Nixon basically you know he in so
many words he was like I'm not putting
makeup on like yeah whatever what are
you some kind of [__] yeah I'm not
doing that
so this was I think it was the first
televised that's the first televised
debate ever and what John Kennedy
understood is that people were gonna see
him and he wanted to be nice and looked
like he wasn't sweating profusely and
looked like he was [__] nervous and
the ability for you to you know keep
cool and collected and in that debate we
have this historically defining moment
where JFK looks you know they [__]
powdered him they dry up the sweat that
they had during commercial breaks all
this stuff Nixon was like [__] oh man
uh you know what he looked like he
looked like [__] uh he looked like
Donald Trump in that interview with
Chris Wallace when he was like so when
is that Health Care gonna come he's like
two weeks it's gonna come in two weeks
climate change is a hoax
speaking of a hoax Donald Trump was at
the debate last night this is a scene of
Donald Trump and Chris Christie
apparently backstage apparently
backstage let's let's take a look
like literally just walk away just walk
away oh ouch are you kidding me
[Music]
ouch
I would have I would have added in some
audio of somebody
[Music]
uh it's it's too funny and yes I do want
to acknowledge something I saw someone
in the chat that was like what about
Bridge gate yes Bridge Gate Bridge gate
is a thing it's not it's not something
that people should ignore Chris Christie
if you and for anyone who doesn't know
about Bridge gate look it up I recommend
well it's definitely something that will
be used against him if he ever got to a
position
be actually a a front runner or someone
who had the chance let me let me
reassure you let me reassure you let me
reassure you let me reassure you really
quick before we get to a piece of
breaking news before we have to go let
me reassure you Chris Christie will not
be the nominee uh for the Republican
party yes in 2024 he's not he's not
gonna get close again they were booing
him when he said the word constitution
on stage I don't know if he caught that
but when he said the word constitution
they were booing him so he's not going
to come anywhere near but Chris Christie
is no [__] Saint here
um and and you and you should and you
should be advised as much but I want to
give you some breaking news here before
we go now Kyle Griffin is reporting uh
Reuters or he's reporting for Reuters
here he's giving the headline Fulton
County D.A Bonnie Willis proposes
October 23rd
2023 Stanford trial against Trump
and Cody
so so Halloween so so we're so we're
we're getting to 2023 now if you're
doing math this is not a very long time
uh for me if you're doing math
um finding Willis is going to be swiftly
rejected for this uh trial yeah yeah
yeah I mean was it was his was it this
one that he proposed 2026
okay okay yeah which which they'll give
the same proposals for all the others
yeah like they're they're gonna they're
gonna continue to try to say no you
gotta punt it past the election which
again uh Bonnie Willis is making it
known that she wants to hurry to trial
but it's not her decision folks that's
the other thing that I keep hearing is
that oh Bonnie Will's Gonna Hurt Bonnie
Wells does not control the process in
the courtroom she does not control it
that's the whole point of Justice that's
the whole point of it and again if they
can do it to you they should be able to
do it to him just like just like in a
courtroom you should be able to be
afforded the same rights as Donald Trump
should be afforded now you're not
because it is a two-tier justice system
but I do I do love the fact that Kenneth
cheese bro was like uh yeah let's just
get this thing over with man speedy
trial I I think that's another tactic
from the Trump team uh they're they're
they're trying because there's so many
defendants in this the one thing that
they know
because this is and they're all lawyers
right
and I use that term loosely but they're
all they're all um or once were bar
holding attorneys now
the thing that they know is there's 19
defendants and there's possibly going to
be more possibly less depending on who
flips but one thing they know is the
more stupid [__] that they submit in the
court each one of them the longer this
is going to draw out they know this
funny Willis knows this that's why
Finding Willis is like yes October 23rd
this year [__] which God damn that's
not too far away but it's it's not gonna
happen she's going to be swiftly
rejected uh for this trial it's just
it's just someone says on Discord trial
tomorrow
yeah go for it man trial trial by combat
I mean if that's what they want to do I
honestly that's how they wanted to do it
remember if it moves into early next
year I mean he's looking at January
February March April June are like I
think almost every month or like maybe
there might be one month out of that
batch that is missing
but in the first half of 2024 yeah he
got he has a trial starting in a variety
of cases and they're not even all four
and they're not even the 4-1 the the
four that he's got going on right now
now here's here's what I'll tell you
about that because I'm I'm excited about
that as far as content goes oh my God
folks nothing would please me more than
this gadgets to keep in a courtroom and
video of this guy in a courtroom nothing
would please me more trust me in and out
and here's but here's the thing is that
the other thing that judges are not
going to do is judges are not going to
risk their trial in their courtroom to
be stepped on by another trial in
another courtroom you have to keep that
in mind this guy is in such legal Peril
in so many jurisdictions that's why it's
going to take so long to unwind all this
[__] and get to him sitting in the seat
and the jury judging him
it's going to take a while because all
that stuff has to unwind and all those
pieces have to fit perfectly into place
so having him charged in this many
jurisdictions actually is not a good
thing to get him to Justice faster it's
not it's it's a hindrance to get him to
Justice faster this Trump being charged
in all these jurisdictions and all these
charges and all these different places
it helps him delay all this [__] it
helps him it does not hurt him I I hate
to Bear a bad news here but yes Justice
will be slow because there is so much
Justice to be brought against Donald
Jessica Trump and we're going to see his
mug shot break the internet this evening
and we'll be back tomorrow we're going
to show you the [__] mug shot
tomorrow yeah when I'll make it I'm
gonna make a second mug out of it I
would almost bet that it's going to end
up on the thumbnail what do you think do
you think yeah
I mean I'll have to do some
photoshopping right yeah I'll get it
that [__] is definitely that
mother [__] is already ending up
on the thumbnail so join us tomorrow
don't forget make sure to subscribe
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
it's free99 hit the Subscribe button hit
the like button if you don't like us but
[__] you hit the dislike button but keep
showing up every single day every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific also visit
the Discord go to the Tony michaels.com
the Discord link is down in in the list
and just go to the Discord where the
chat never stops follow us on Twitch all
these links are on the Tony michaels.com
so go to the Tony michaels.com to follow
us every single place you can and again
tomorrow we're gonna have the mug shot
for you we're gonna have all the story
for you about how the guy's got the perp
walk and the whole nine yards be here
be here tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon